this video is brought to you by movie
get 30 days for free by going to movie
comm slash now you see it like many
other franchises and ensemble films the
x-men series had the challenge of
juggling several character arcs while
still maintaining a story that spans
over multiple films in fact the biggest
influence on the x-men sequel acts 2 was
another sequel from another huge
franchise you may have heard of it have
for me with you
the production team referred to X 2 as
the x-men equivalent to the Star Wars
sequel The Empire Strikes Back both
films made established characters split
apart and come to their own realizations
X 2 effectively adapted this concept for
its own characters film and film series
and the scene that best captures how the
film executes this idea is when Xavier
and the x-men infiltrate the Oval Office
to warn the president of the coming war
in the third x-men film the scene takes
place after Stryker tried to brainwash
Xavier into using his powers to wipe out
all mutants Xavier tells the president
what happened and reminds him that the
mutants aren't going anywhere and in the
future humans and mutants need to work
together to bring peace we're here to
stay and mr. president
the next move is yours at first glance
the scene may seem like just an easy way
to set up the sequel but it's actually
packed with an impressive amount of
depth finishing up several character
arcs and summing up the movie itself all
while looking awesome so let's take a
look at how this excellent scene gives
closure to the struggles of multiple
characters in the film and addresses the
main theme of the entire x-men franchise
in this time of adversity we are being
offered a moment before we even see any
x-men in this scene we get hints that
multiple mutants are about to show up
first we see lightning in here Thunder
and we instantly know it's not just bad
weather it's the mutant storm storms
powers always signal her arrival before
we see her and it reminds us of an
earlier moment in the film when she did
the exact same thing then the president
notices everyone is frozen in place so
we now know Xavier is involved too
because everybody freezing reminds the
viewer of a similar moment in the
beginning of the film so before we even
see the mutants the visuals of the scene
primed the viewer for the epic payoff of
the team appearing in the Oval Office
good morning mr. president
and the combination of freezing
characters and using lightning creates
an amazing image but the final scene
goes beyond cool visuals the dialogue is
actually extremely multi-layered for
such a seemingly simple scene it's
filled with character payoffs that
neatly tie up the events of the film for
Logan Xavier speech makes him empathize
with Cyclops and has been casualties
losses on both sides and they sort of
come to terms with each other in the
next scene and he also got another more
subtle moment throughout the film
there's a recurring theme that Logan
abandons people he'll be here when we
get back
unless you plan on running off again I
could be the good guy sticks around and
he later fulfills this prophecy
where's no
it's calm but in the end he rejects that
past self and embraces his role in the
x-men by the time he's at the White
House he completes this character arc
when he gets a line saying he'll stick
around we'll be watching
similarly Xavier his dialogue also calls
back to his actions in the film in this
scene the x-men give the president files
that show Stryker was trying to kill all
the mutants
how did you get this well let's just say
I know a little girl who can walk
through walls with such a diverse group
of superheroes there were tons of ways
for Xavier to get those files I think
the writers wanted Xavier to have the
little girl from his school get the
files because it reminds us of earlier
in the film when Jason Stryker used an
illusion of a little girl to
mind-control Xavier the film even refers
to both the illusion and the actual
student as a little girl she's just no
she's not like many other x-men movies
Xavier character arc revolves around his
ability to nurture younger mutants and
because he gets captured he's unable to
protect his students from the government
but now and then every mother needs to
get away without her the babies are
helpless the illusion is - mind controls
Xavier is a former student who Xavier
failed to save Jason is a living example
of Xavier Sphere that he won't be able
to help his students at this point in
the movie Xavier can't protect them and
he can't use them to do good it's
actually turned into the opposite
instead of mentoring students a student
now mentors him giving him instructions
on what to do the whole scene puts
Xavier at his lowest harming mutants
instead of mentoring them but once he's
at the white house he has repaired his
mentor student relationships
he now mentors a little girl from his
school to use her powers for the greater
good how did you get this well let's
just say I know a little girl who can
walk through walls by connecting the
illusionist and this scene with a
similar character the dialog shows
Xavier has moved on from his failures as
a teacher and has resumed his role as a
caring mentor and even without any
dialogue the other characters in the
scene get their own moments earlier in
the film rogue and Iceman both wanted
superhero uniforms
to arrive in a few years and by the
final scene they've already got them
showing that they've proved themselves
as x-men and it's cool to have
Nightcrawler back in the Oval Office
because it reminds us of the opening of
the film when he acted much differently
there
his small back-and-forth with the
president in this scene reminds us that
his character was nothing like the
menacing monster from the opening scene
in a way he gets a small bit of
redemption by showing the president his
true self
just like with Logan Xavier rogue and
Iceman Nightcrawler got a moment in the
scene to show his transformation my
crawlers redemption in the White House
signals some broader payoffs in the
story as a whole the film begins with a
mutant creating chaos in a United States
government building initiating the
tenuous relationship between the mutes
and community and the government in
direct contrast to the chaos of the
first scene in the White House this one
feels methodical and exacts instead of
the camera whipping around in confusion
it moves slowly and with purpose and
instead of everyone being thrown around
they are perfectly still it brings a
sense of conclusion to the tension in
the very beginning that set off the plot
of the film but this scene goes even
deeper than just this one movie the
entire franchise of x-men deals with one
central question should mutants work
with humans or fight against them this
scene shows a little bit of both Xavier
trusts humanity more than Magneto that
was the central disagreement of the
first x-men film but after the events of
this movie Xavier has clearly seen the
potential danger of the government
knowing the whereabouts of every mutant
when given the option the government let
Stryker try to destroy all mutants and
that event changed Xavier strategy
towards dealing with humans you can see
his transformation when comparing the
White House scene with the other time
Xavier froze humans in that earlier
scene he freezes to stop mutants from
using their powers in public the next
time you feel like showing off don't but
this time he lets the president see
their power so Xavier can sent a message
so in this scene the mutants act a
little more like magneto they do show
what they're capable of in an
intimidating way but they still make it
clear that they want to use that power
for good
mr. president this is not a threat this
is an opportunity in a first for the
franchise
Xavier no longer completely relies on
the goodwill of politicians this time he
extends an olive branch but he also
makes sure that the president knows the
mutants won't go down without a fight
we're here to stay mr.
the next move is yours so not only does
this scene wrap up the arcs of
individual characters but it also wraps
up the collective arc of all the mutants
both in this film and in the film series
up to this point through their
collective struggles the mutants learn
to no longer hide in the shadows and
instead to use their power for the
betterment of themselves their entire
race and humanity and after looking at
this scene closely the influences from
The Empire Strikes Back become perfectly
clear both films have characters who
mature a new cast member who gains the
trust of the group and a mix of
uncertainty and hope at the end the fact
that both these films used very similar
tropes to tell such different stories
shows the brilliance behind this
narrative structure they both set up the
conflict to give characters their own
personal struggles and then reunite
those characters to fill their
individual arcs and bring the entire
story to mint annex two managed to pack
a lot of that payoff ball at once in one
excellent seen many blockbusters
including other x-men films set up a
sequel by sticking a small teaser into
the post-credits but in this scene x2
not only laid the groundwork for a
sequel but also perfectly wrapped up the
conflicts within the characters and the
film itself based on the presentation of
this scene it's no surprise that the
original x-men series easily managed
storylines for many characters at once
and set the standard for world building
in a large cinematic universe
this video is part of the one excellent
scene series about the x-men film
franchise we all hand-picked a scene we
loved from the x-men to show what makes
these girls great and for a similar
personal curated experience when it
comes to exploring more films I highly
recommend movie movie is a curated
streaming service that shows exceptional
films from around the world
what makes this service stand out is
that every day movie presents a new film
hand selected by their team of curators
so you'll always have something great to
watch they have tons of timeless
classics award-winning masterpieces and
festival fresh Jens the kinds of films I
definitely want to be watching Maura
to start I'd recommend watching Junoon a
fascinating documentary directed by Paul
Thomas Anderson about the making of the
album Junoon inside of a giant Ford in
India you can try movie for free for 30
days at movie.com slash now you see it
that's mu bi comm slash now you see it
for a whole month of great cinema for
free a big thanks to movie for
sponsoring and thanks to you our patrons
for your support if you want to support
our work directly join our patreon
thanks for watching
[Music]